hi everyone today I'm going to talk an
interactive for proximity with global
oblivious queries this is a giant work
with the Dell girl life and guide what
to do
starting off our work focuses on models
and as chats we'll need to define a
baseline model and to compare ourselves
to and to build our definitions on and
this model will be of probability
testing
in probability testing we have a subset
of strings of length and we're
interested in we've got it the poverty
and denote it by time and we'll need to
design what we call a tester which will
denote by T which and which will get a
query access to some input X which means
that it will be able to look at specific
indices of X and read the bits and our
tester needs to satisfy two conditions
the first one is that if x is in the
property then we will like our tester to
Output yes with high probability and
otherwise if x is formed from from the
property which means that the Hamming
distance of X and N is string in the
property is large then we want our
tester to Output knowing hypoallability
and follow the testing we want to
minimize the number of queries that the
tester makes to the input X which we
call a coil complexity and denoted by QT
and natural extension of probability
testing is the model of interactive
proximity which I'll denote by iotp
in this model we again have this
interesting poverty bye and but now our
tester will be called the verify because
now it is verifying and additionally to
a same access to the input X we now have
a over P which knows the entirety of X
which is highlighted by the fact that
here is X is input and V is able to
communicate with a p and ask it
questions about X and
as before we want to be our verifier to
satisfy the condition the first one is
if x is in the property then we want
that to exist some over that will make
our verifiers say yes we have
probability
and otherwise if x is found from the
probability like I defined in the pop in
the property testing case then we want
no matter what the proverb will do the
verify will output now will have
probability so the folder even though it
knows the entirety of X and we might not
look at all positions of X we want the
power not to be able to convince a v to
Output yes mistakenly
and like in popularity testing we're
interested to minimize the number of
queries that we may expect but now
additionally we want to also minimize
the number of bits communicated between
vnp and also a measure that we're
interested in is the number of messages
exchanged between V and B and just to be
clear about it in this picture we have
vlp communicating three messages and
although its methods can contain
um
some number of bits not necessarily one
so these are two different methods but
they are connected
so and that's our question to ask is
well okay we added a portal to the
equation and now did we really increase
the power of the model and specifically
we would like to show an exponential gap
between property testing and tactical
proximity and which means to show a
specific probability and for which we
have a specific inductive for proximity
such that the coil complexity times the
communication complexity is
exponentially smaller than the coil
complexity of any test that we can make
for this uh probability and actually the
question was already Answers by Answers
by working with us and we also defined
the model of inductive for proximity and
they show that yes this is possible
connection Gap and furthermore in
another work Google and what Bloom
showed that we can show an exponential
Gap even when the portal is restricted
to just send one message to read so the
whole communication is the power sending
one message to the verify and even under
this section we can already show an
exponential guard which means that the
model of electrical activity is
relatively powerful compared to property
testing
so that's nice and we'll not do focus on
the verifying inductive of proximity and
highlight the fact that it engages in
two inherently different type of
activities the first activity is
querying X which means looking at
specific bits of X but knowing that they
are always correct and the second
activity is communicating with the proof
of being who knows the entirety of X but
the overall may be untruthful it can lie
even though it can answer a very
complicated questions about X and an
interactive of proximity we basically do
not limit the amount of coordination we
have between these two activities and we
can maybe query X in some locations and
then Challenge B
um on these bits so that P will not will
not be able to cheat and the other
direction the pool will may tell us hey
look at the specific index of X and this
is where you will find your answer and
we can do that
[Music]
um
and our question in our work we asked
the question whether this free
coordination we have between these two
activities is essential to get this Gap
exponential gap between the power of
inductive proximity and property testing
um and a specific type of this
restriction which appears naturally in
in some cases is the is the Restriction
of Provo oblivious queries in this
restriction we limit the
um coordination the possible
coordination in the direction of P2
querying X in another world this means
that the queries that V Max to X can
only depend on the internal randomness
of the verifier and the input X
whichever hover that we are talking with
and whatever the portal says will not
impact the positions we look at X and
that's why it's called over oblivious
queries
and and
I said that this is natural so here's
some motivation for this type of section
if we have a protocol which in which the
verify makes probably the square is the
coins can be prepared in advance to the
approval coming even even if the profile
does not exist at this point it will
come in the future and try to convince
us that X belongs to some property we
can already ask the questions uh in
advance and another more practical one
is uh in a walk by Vermont
and which show that any interactive
proximity which satisfies this photo
oblivious questions
and can be transformed to a natural con
lotion of their knowledge for this
problem
and
okay so we have this reflection that we
are going to focus on which is the polo
reverse queries and in order to talk
about this more easily and we want to
alter the model with active volcanity
slightly from another decrease it's
power and by what we call a verified
decomposition so we take our previously
called verify and we split it into three
parts the first part we'll call the
querying path which will be able to
query X but not communicate with t the
second part is the interacting part
which we're able to communicate with B
but not query X and the third part is
the decision path which will receive the
whole view of both the querying pattern
the entirely file and we'll have to
decide whether to Output yes or now and
this whole box is what we previously
called V and so we decomposed V into
three parts and an interactive proximity
we basically allowed a free
communication between these two parts
and and that that's the way they were
able to coordinate whatever they query
to X or whatever they call it to be and
just to be clear about it I am not
counting this communication inside the
communication complexity the
complexities are still the same the
number of places that Q logs at X and
the number of bits and messages
communicated between I and P
and
to compare this to the over oblivious
queries and restriction and we limit
this direction of communication between
I and Q if Q does not receive any
information from I then inherently the
queries that Q makes to X must be over
oblivious
okay
[Music]
um
looking more more slowly in the other
direction of coordination between q and
I we actually identified three different
models of over oblivious screws and we
sort of get this over oblivious quality
style okay so I'm not extreme if we
limit the communication completely in
the either direction between q and I we
end up with what we call the isolated
model in which q and I are completely
separate entities we highlight it by
showing that they're initiated with a
independent Randomness Roku and why
On The Other Extreme if we do not limit
at all what Q might send to life we end
up with a general probabilities model
which is the strongest overview square
is model
um in which Q can send anything it wants
to I so that means it can send its
internal Randomness in the queries it
makes and the answers to the queries and
interestingly there is actually an
intermediate model between these two
models and in which q a only share a
common Randomness between them we call
this model pre-coordinated model and
denoted by the fact that they receive a
shared Randomness draw between I and Q
but there is no other other
communication so compared to the general
probably the police model Q cannot send
to I anything so it cannot send the
answers to the query it makes maybe some
queries are determined by this shared
Randomness but maybe some are determined
by X and I will not be able to know them
and compared to the isolated model well
q and I were completely independent
entities now they can be dependent in
some way based on these common elements
so that's nice we have some sort of
hierarchy of overall related studies and
an actual question to ask at this point
is whether the exponential Gap that we
have or effect for interactable Infinity
which only requires sending just one
message between the verifier and the
power also holds for this model or did
this restriction of rivers queries and
further remote restricting how q and I
and
coordinates severely limits the power so
I'm going to answer this question
regarding the pre-coordinator model so
let's take the theorem and show an
exponential Gap in the recover limited
model we are going to show to see a
property time that satisfies two
conditions the first one regarding
testing says that any tester for pi must
have
um Quality complexity which is Omega n
which means that relatively any tester
for pi must make many queries and in
comparison also going to show and a big
column in the protocol for pi in which
vlp or whether imp communicate three
messages for a total communication law
which is logarithm and in air and the
quelling part will only query X at a
constant number of positions so
comparing Q times C to this
um lower bound on the coil complexity of
any tester we achieve an exponential gap
for this property by
between the black hole and the model and
the property testing model
so let's start with with defining the
property so the probability will consist
of any string of the form uuvv such that
UVS and string of length uh n over 2. so
a little visualization of how this uh
things in this spot what they look like
so this thing is in this property if we
can can cut it in some position not
necessarily in the middle such that the
first part of the string is too
consecutive identical strings and the
second part of the string is two
consecutive identical strings and
okay and and why adjusting this out so
actually this is already shown by a walk
by Prof alone and secondly we showed
that any test of all this specific
property must make a relatively many
queries to test so at least at least
square root n and a little bit on why
this block out is difficult so given a
cut we actually can easily test whether
a string is in this property or not what
will what the tester will do it will
sample a random position in the string I
and now that we have I and the the cuts
it to you will can only Define the
matching position of I in the other copy
of the string that we found under the
cut to you so if we query in this
location I its matching Position will be
in the other copy of v and we can ask
the same question whether this is a two
the bits in these two locations are
identical or not but the issue for the
tester is that it doesn't know where to
cut the string like this thing can be
cut there and then and there
um so in in a sense a tester will need
to test all possible Cuts in order to
determine that a string is far from Main
property and which means that this
property is relatively hard for testing
so the description of what I gave you
for testing once you know the cut gives
a very simple inductive for proximity
for this property so it is proximity we
have V and the blue will simply send the
claimed correct cut to you to the
verifier and the verifier can do exactly
as we said a concept number of times and
check this uh tell us of matching
positions to determine whether the power
cheated or is running the tour
and but the issue at least for us in
this very nice inductor for proximity Is
that it's not probably this we can fit
it in any of the three models that we
discussed before and why is that so a
sampling position I'm quelling at
position I is indeed for probably yes
but the matching positions of eye under
the cut to you depend on the cut that
the povert sends and if the cover would
have sent a different category would
query in a different position and
therefore this second query that we make
is power dependent so we need we need to
take this idea of the over telling us
the cut and change it by a little bit so
let me describe the precoordinated
protocol for this property so here we
have Qi we have X coaxis to input X and
we have we can interact with the
probability I will start by saying
what's the shell Randomness in this
quick alternative model is so it will
simply be a random index out of n and
which will denote by little I and which
both q and I know
and the coiling part will very simply
just query X at position and get back a
x the bit x i and the interacting module
will start communicating with P we have
three messages remember we want to show
the gap for three messages in the
playground model and we'll start by the
approval sending the cut to you as with
the interactive holds anything and so
notice that at this point what I know it
knows little I so it knows the position
that Q would query X and he knows that
the the claimed cut position that will
send it
um so at this point I know the little
eye and the matching positions of little
eye another is cut to you but the issue
that it's kind of communicate this
messing position to kill and in order
for Q to query Alexa so instead we'll
ask the poster to provide us this
location but the issue is that the Uber
may be cheating so we need to do
something uh smart so we'll Define I
zero to be little I and I want to be the
metric position of I under the cut
studio that uh the interacting mode part
knows and it will also flip a coin which
will denote by this B
and we sent to the power uh the index IV
so the probability half we will send the
index that we actually Acquired and then
we've already have we'll send the
matching position of the this location
and the power will have to send back a
bit which is supposed to be exit
position ID
so finally I'll have to to say what the
deciding part will do so I and Q will
send the views to the designing path
which will simply test whether these
bits that the querying power said query
matching matches the bit that the pover
sent at the end of the interaction
um
so why why this
protocol works
so let's start with the with the
condition in which X is in the property
so if if x is in a property then there
is some cut to you and that satisfy this
condition the honest people can simply
send this correct cat and then no matter
which uh position we ask AI or the
matching position Y and these two
indices point at the same bit so the
power can simply say this bit and send
this bit back and it will always be
equal to uh the bits that required and
we will always accept and we will always
say yes in the other direction if if x
is far forming in in the property this
means that no matter which
cuts the approval claims to be the
correct cut with high probability over
this index I that we assemble a i in the
metric position of I will point to
different bits and I will not agree
because this this x is performing in the
property and and both when it gets this
index that we asked it to provide it
doesn't know whether it's the index that
we actually queried or the magic
position of the of the index the only
thing you see is is two different bits
so it will have to at best guess which
one we actually queried and therefore by
checking whether this bit that equation
is equal to the video provides will
catch a statistic over with Mobility at
least half and we increase this to any
constant higher probability by instead
of sampling just one eye and we will
sample a constant number of indices I
so let's go back to the theorem we
already showed that the previous work
showed the first part the second part we
show the click on the model which we
proved to be true and the querying model
we say just queries X at positions I we
said
that we want a constant number of these
positions which means that the querying
complexity will be a constant and in the
interaction a p and I exchange three
messages we satisfy this condition and
and the things that they actually
communicate so to you is just a size
which can be communicated in a
logarithmic amount of bits and this is
an index which can also be communicated
logarithmic amount of base and this is
just one bit and so repeating this for a
constant number of times we get that the
communication complexity is although of
a login
and so to have this theorem up we showed
a pre-coordinated uh
protocol which shows an exponential gap
between the pre-coordinated model and
property testing
to finish up this talk let's say call
our three models here on the right side
and try to answer the questions for all
this model models is there an
exponential Gap from testing
and I'm going to present this uh the
answer to the question in this table in
the rows we'll have our three models and
in our columns we have the different
number of messages that we allow I and P
to communicate
and starting off in in one message all
of these models collapse to the same
model and in previous work in they
collapsed the same model of over
oblivious questions and obvious work
that they referenced them by Google they
showed that
um no matter what we that there cannot
be an exponential gap between the model
of reverse queries and property testing
and we extend this result for the
entirety of the isolated model so we
show that no matter how many messages we
allow I and P to communicate inside and
they ask as long as we are in the
isolation model we cannot show an
exponential from testing so there is a
model is inherently as weak as property
testing
and we also show this result for the
preconded model when the I and D are
limited to exchanging these two messages
and as I just proven in the theorem
before and for three messages in the big
auditing model we do have an exponential
Gap from testing and in the general
probability of the square is model we
show that only two messages are enough
to show an exponential Gap and and now
that we have this table on screen
let's recall that in a inductive
proximity without this construction of
other oblivious cars we just needed one
message in order to show an exponential
Gap in the power of interactive for
proximity compared to popularity testing
and once we went into the Super
oblivious queries models and we needed
to add at least one message in order to
show a gap and if we went further and
limited the amount of coordination
between these two entities q and I and
we needed three messages in order to
show an exponential Gap and once we went
to the extreme and completely and
disallowed the coordination between
these two entities and we show that we
weaken the model too much and now it
cannot be much stronger than properly
testing
so that's it and thank you for listening